as you heard there are some of the
pro-trump rioters were chanting hang
mike pence there was even a news hanging
up
as a rant as they ransacked the capital
the vice president was forced to shelter
in place for hours
along with his wife and his daughter who
were also in the building at the time
paula reed is at the white house with
more on this story paula we all know the
vice president has been very loyal
extremely loyal to president trump how
was their relationship now i hear that
the president hasn't even contacted him
since wednesday
good morning gail despite that history
of loyalty
sources tell cbs news that president
trump has not spoken with his vice
president since wednesday
even despite these death threats now
president trump has also come under
criticism
for waiting until yesterday to order all
u.s flags at half staff in honor of the
two capitol police officers
who died since the riot nowhere told the
president he's here at the white house
but he's largely
alone and surrounded by only a few close
advisers
including his chief of staff and his
son-in-law jared kushner
he's of course now permanently banned
from twitter but he is looking for new
ways we are told
to communicate and try to change the
conversation
tomorrow he is expected to head to the
southern border and later today he is
expected to bestow
the medal of freedom the highest
civilian honor
on congressman jim jordan and jordan was
among the lawmakers who challenged the
electoral college results on wednesday
after that deadly attack on the capitol
anthony
paula thank you